When we last saw Dexter Morgan, he had abandoned
his young son, faked his death, and become,
well, a lumberjack — complete with a big beard
and his own small trailer in the middle of Oregon.
The new revival of the popular Dexter series
on Showtime, set eight years after the finale,
will see the well-meaning titular serial
killer, played by Michael C. Hall,
living under an assumed identity in Iron Lake, New
York. He'll be dealing with new setbacks and foes,
including the villainous Mayor Caldwell, played by
Clancy Brown, and Chief of Police Angela Bishop,
played by Julia Jones. As executive producer
Clyde Phillips warned viewers, heads will roll.
"This is Dexter. People are going to die."
When John Lithgow was added to the revival,
however, fans were understandably curious about
what his actual role would be; his character,
Arthur Mitchell, AKA the Trinity Killer,
was killed by Dexter at the end of Season 4.
How exactly does someone come back from that,
especially with Dexter's patented methods
that assure his victims are truly gone?
John Lithgow won an Emmy for his
frightening work as Mitchell and
was arguably a pivotal character on the
show. He was a foil for Dexter who could
seemingly balance his double life as a serial
killer with his role as a husband and father.
In some ways, Dexter finally found
someone he could relate to as a person,
at least when it came to his most primal desires
and the justifications of his actions. By killing
Dexter's wife Rita, however, the Trinity Killer —
a man who was abusive toward his own family — put
an end to Dexter's dream of "having it all" as
both a killer and a family man. Dexter kills
Mitchell and the Trinity Killer persona along with
him, though his inner peace is still years away.
We can speculate about how Arthur will return
to the show, but according to Deadline,
Lithgow is only working for about a day on set. If
this is the case, it's unlikely that his character
will be a consistent presence during the revival.
We also don't expect him to portray someone other
than Mitchell, as the Trinity Killer is still one
of the most unsettling characters in all of TV.
There must be a specific reason
that Lithgow has rejoined the show,
and for this, we need to look deeply
into the personality of Dexter.
How long can Dexter suppress his natural urges?
That should be one of the biggest questions you
ask when the new episodes air. Away from the
constant threat and temptation that a "normal"
life brought him, Dexter's new weapon of choice is
an axe. But instead of cutting into human flesh,
he's cutting into trees. It can't
possibly be what he really wants,
could it? Somewhere inside, an inner voice
pokes at him, reminding him of his true nature.
"Hello … Dexter Morgan"
While Dexter may have decided toward the end of
his run as a killer that he no longer needs the
Code, that doesn't mean his demons have left.
The Trinity Killer took Dexter's wife away,
cutting deeper than any blade. It's
not much of a stretch to think that
the Dark Passenger could return. But
this time, what if it bears a new face?
A simple reminder of who Dexter is and what
he's capable of wouldn't take much dialogue.
Lithgow probably didn't need more than a day
on set to deliver an emotionally
compelling exchange with Dexter.
Their scene, or scenes, could be the
catalyst that causes Dexter to return to
his murderous life. Or it might be a final
catharsis for the former forensics master.
Although The Trinity Killer is back, that doesn't
mean Dexter will snap and murder the first person
who he thinks deserves it. Let's be honest,
though: What is Dexter without a high body count?
Viewers aren't going to return for the reformed
killer who has conquered his emotional and mental
instabilities. Closure for the audience
may not be the same as closure for Dexter,
and we won't be surprised if Arthur Mitchell is
the spark that lights a new fire in Dexter's soul.
We'll find out exactly how Arthur Mitchell will
return to Dexter when the revival
premieres in the fall of 2021.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about Showtime's
"Dexter" revival are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.